ils sont français américains ukrainiens
ou même russe depuis le début du conflit
huit journalistes ont été tués par les
forces russes d'après reporters sans
frontières la plupart aura été visés
délibérément
c'est le cas du réalisateur mantas gré
des radis su ce qui a été tué par balles
le 2 avril après avoir été retenu
prisonnier par les forces russes le 23
mars
c'est une des seules journalistes russes
présentes en ukraine oksana bao li na
qui est assassiné par un drone explosif
à kiev
le 14 mars une équipe de fox news est la
cible de tirs à ojén qu'après de la
capitale ukrainienne le caméraman franco
irlandais et la journaliste ukrainienne
olexandre akouchi nova meurt dans l'
attaque rsf affirme que 120 journalistes
ont été délibérément ciblé par les
forces russes depuis le début du conflit
c'est derrière ces huit journalistes
tués des dizaines et des dizaines d'
attaques délibérées contre des
journalistes avec parfois des miracles
des journalistes qui ont survécu alors
que tout avait été fait par les fortes
les forces russes pour les assassiner
max levin un photo journaliste américain
a été tué le 13 mars il couvre une zone
de combat dans la banlieue de kiev sa
dépouille a été découverte après le
retrait des forces russes il portait une
veste presse les infrastructures
médiatiques sont également prises pour
cible la tour de télévision de kiev a
été bombardé tuant ainsi le caméraman
ukrainien evgueni sakoun le 1er mars une
semaine après le début du conflit